hello my name is Rahul Mandalay and I'll
leave new business creation within
deloitte's life sciences and healthcare
practice with me is my colleague Jurgen
Planck who is our precision medicine
leader we are here today to examine the
future of biomedical research we are
going to look both at how biomedical
research has been conducted to date and
how the landscape is changing as well as
a potential solution that we are using
to address this innovative field
biomedical research is at a unique
juncture it is increasingly turning to
data science to make new discoveries for
treatments let me give you three
examples of drivers that are causing
this change and the resulting needs for
data science first there are large
volumes of data now available orders of
magnitude more than before that need to
be stored for efficient use this
includes the traditional sets of science
generated data such as genomics data
imaging data clinical data but also
patient generated data from variables
and environmental data and explore
exposure data these data are now being
collected in ever increasing quantities
and there is an exception expectation
that if they can be easily stored and
analyzed they can help drive new
discoveries and treatment options thus
there is a huge need for storage and
efficient search capabilities for
biomedical data second there is an
interest in driving deeper into
precision medicine by using artificial
intelligence researchers want to
understand how the body functions at all
levels starting at the molecular level
then at the cellular level and the organ
level take Cystic Fibrosis is an example
researchers found the correlation
between the CFTR gene and the disease
leading to the understanding that a
mutation in the CFTR gene was the cause
of cystic fibrosis from this discovery a
new treatment could be developed and two
years ago the FDA granted a breakthrough
therapy designation
to a particular gene therapy that
addressed the mutated gene however in
most cases the relation between genetic
mutation and disease is much more
complex it is not a one mutated gene
causes one disease situation so
researchers need to go further they need
to understand how the body functions at
the molecular level looking at all genes
and proteins in action
within cells and organs this will
require the development of new
artificial intelligence methods that can
analyze all of the data available
thus biomedical research is becoming a
huge computational task third there are
an estimated 7,000 rare diseases of
which only 500 have treatments and even
fewer of cures thus there's an urgent
call to researchers to share all of
their data to rapidly advance the
discovery of new treatments while each
of these 7,000 diseases may be rare
individually the total tally affects a
significant number across the population
to not be learned that cancer is not
just one disease but rather it is a
collection of many different types of
cancer some of which are very rare we
need to understand what is happening to
the body with each of these different
cancer types in order to find cures by
sharing the data with the research
community there is an opportunity to
perform new analysis and make new
discoveries let me summarize - make new
discoveries and find new treatments
biomedical researchers will need to be
able to store analyze and share all of
their data at scale we are now going to
look at a particular use case that
focuses on the necessary steps to share
data without compromising privacy the
biomedical data be used for research are
collected from humans and ensuring the
privacy of these data dollars is
critical without it we would put at risk
the trust given to scientists by these
data donors
the HIPAA Privacy Rule establishes the
conditions under which protected health
information or pH I may be used or
disclosed for research purposes in short
HIPAA requires that all pahi be
de-identified before data are shared in
addition other laws require that all
personally identifiable information or
PII also be be identified our use case
focuses on the D identification of
imaging data for cancer cardiovascular
and pulmonary research a critical step
before these images can be shared with
the research community on this slide you
will see a pair of lung x-rays today
most CT scans MRIs and x-rays use the
DICOM standard which stands for digital
imaging and communications and medicine
DICOM data has a header which includes
pH I and PII data see the red boxes on
the top left and right in addition the
pH I and PII can be found on the image
itself see the red box at the bottom we
are working with our client on a pilot
to ensure their patient's data is
de-identified by removing masking or
encrypting the sensitive PhIP III data
before images are shared to do this we
are using Google's healthcare API as an
out-of-the-box solution in our pilot we
are working to answer two questions how
reliable is the D identification process
and what is achievable throughput of the
process this is important as we are
working to do this at scale as you can
see de-identified data just from images
is a large undertaking and this is only
one of many steps that must be taken to
prepare data for large-scale analytic
efforts if we take a step back and look
at all the steps required for biomedical
research we realize that what we need is
an efficient solution that provides the
biomedical community
but the ability to store analyze and
share their data at scale we will now
discuss how we can build such an
environment that meets these needs on
the Google cloud platform
however we should note that a technical
solution alone will not be sufficient to
create a tithing ecosystem of biomedical
research that widely shares their data
there are several non technical
challenges that must be overcome but
they are beyond the scope of this
presentation I'm now going to hand over
to virgon to walk us through the details
of the GCP based solution thanks for who
to start let's examine the principles of
a biomedical research data science
solution as Raul mentioned there are
three key functional requirements the
ability to effectively store and manage
data the ability to analyze data at
scale and the ability to share data with
the community and effectively used to
share data let's look at each of these
three in turn starting with data
organization a foundational principle
for organizing biomedical data is the
concept of fair data fair stands for
findable accessible interoperable and
reusable let's look at each one each of
these mean fo findable a for accessible
eye for interoperable and R for reusable
starting with findable this means that
all data must be annotated with metadata
that makes the data searchable this must
be possible for all data types the data
should be stored in a data lake and we
need a proper metadata repository data
that is newly ingested should ideally be
annotated with metadata in an automated
or semi-automated way to allow data
ingest at scale finally we need an
efficient search
mechanism that lets us discover data of
interest this must be possible for all
data today most data sit in silos that
cannot be searched from the outside the
next one is a for accessible this means
that there must be an easy way to
request access to data that has been
discovered and is of interest ideally we
don't want to move the data around so
data access really means that I can use
the data to compute on it and quite
possibly compute across many data sets
that may reside in different locations
what we have today again is still mostly
data silos where it is impossible to run
algorithms across the data sets the
third fare data concept is AI for
interoperable now this is where data
standards come into play
unfortunately in biomedical research
there's a myriad of standards at a
minimum data should adhere to a common
standard and we need mappings between
the most common standards and yes by
data standards I also mean semantic
standards such as anthologies and
vocabularies not just syntactic
standards I is probably the hardest of
the four fair principles finally are for
reusable this has to do with data use
agreements and consents and accompany
the data it must be possible to trace
what data are used for so that any
misuse can be discovered in appropriate
measures to protect the data and the
human data donors can be taken when it
comes to the second requirement powerful
data analysis we have to realize that
algorithms are actually just data as
well and thus their codes should also
follow fair principles because in the
end we not only want to share the raw
data but also our analysis
since in order to accelerate innovation
we need an easy-to-use data science
environment that allows us to scale ibly
compute across all of the data of
interest furthermore we want to be able
to reuse already existing algorithms
many of these are encoded in the form of
services that are natively available on
the Google cloud platform the previously
discussed the identification service is
such an algorithm and we need to be able
to access it so the rapidly through its
API in an easy way many other algorithms
are bundled into libraries this could be
machine learning and artificial
intelligence methods for image analysis
or for a genomic study again these
algorithms or libraries must be easily
accessible from within the data science
environment the last requirement is data
sharing we already discussed this as
part of the fair principles but to
reiterate sharing must be possible not
only within teams but also across teams
and even between institutions if we
follow these guiding principles when
building a solution on the Google cloud
platform we will have enabled the
biomedical research community to focus
on what they are best at doing their
research without having to worry about
the underlying technology and hopefully
be able to accelerate discoveries and
new treatment options for the many
untreatable diseases that ALS we have
developed a DCP native reference
implementation for biomedical research
solution that follows the principles we
just discussed you can see some
screenshots on the right and that will
show an architectural diagram later on
the data types we have to handle include
clinical data in the form of electronic
health records often now following the
fire standard genomic data medical and
scientific imaging data radio
images follow the DICOM standard but
pathology images do not consistently
follow that standard and we have also
handled medical supply chain and public
health data labs mostly as part of our
work for the Kobe 19 healthcare
coalition which is a pro bono effort of
almost 1,000 organizations coming
together to share data and perform
studies to combat Kobe 19 we're also
supporting a variety of analytic methods
researchers often prefer to use a
notebook like environment to code their
methods and workflows specifically
Jupiter notebooks that can decode it in
R or in Python to select datasets and
build cohorts but also to generate
downstream analyses bigquery can be
easily used
we also discussed access to
microservices via their API it's a
Google cloud platform
through its many healthcare and
biomedical products offers access to
many services ranging from genomic
analyses to data mapping to image
analytics to advanced machine learning
and artificial intelligence and more
these are powerful tools that we can
bring to the researchers fingertips and
finally we offer the ability to reuse
existing workflows for sharing enabling
true collaboration in method and
algorithm development
now let's take a closer look at the
solution you can see here two
screenshots the Left screenshot shows
the home screen where you can see all of
your projects listed projects are the
big tiles on the screen which show the
project name a short description and the
approved users on the right screenshot
we open one project at the top you can
see the project information again on the
left is the metadata repository which is
searchable and where it can select data
for use as well as share data with
others and on the right side of the
workspace is where I can launch Jupiter
notebooks to perform your analyses
what's important is that this user
interface is intuitive and takes away
from the complexity of the Google cloud
platform itself if I showed the GCP home
screen to a biomedical researcher they
would be overwhelmed by the choices of
tools and often not understand how to
use them how our user interface provides
them with an intuitive screen that they
can understand how to navigate and
perform their work
all the while using the full power of
TCP behind it let's take a look at the
architecture I'll start on the left side
this is where we receive data from
systems such as microscopes or other
devices that can stream their data right
into our environment we can use a
command-line interface to push the data
with a defined frequency or we can
manually load the data the ingest
process uses cloud network and cloud
data fusion to push the data into a
Google cloud storage bucket the metadata
repository near the middle of the slide
serves as an environment to store all
metadata associated with the collected
data upon data ingest the data can be
inspected for tags for example
fire or die contacts that can be used to
automatically generate metadata we use
services provided by the Google
healthcare a P I to the left of the
metadata repository to perform initial
transformations of the data such as the
identification
this requires temporary placement of the
data into a fire or die chrome store
where the D identification service is
being performed we have a data sharing
capability that invokes pops-up firebase
and can leverage services such as
Google's data marketplace to make data
discoverable for search near the top of
the slide we use Apache Solr
and to the right we have notebook
services that utilize GCP stupid lab to
launch notebook services in these
notebooks all the way on the right in
the second box from the top the
researchers can code and execute their
algorithms they can also access GCP
services through what we call
convenience methods which are wrappers
around the api's so that researchers
don't have to learn the detailed command
syntax of an API call but instead can
use a very simple and intuitive commands
have just de-identified with some simple
arguments for security we use the native
GCP security layer which provides
Identity and Access Management
and offers a very granular role based
data access cost management is also
built-in to allow researchers to see the
cost of a service before they use it
above all we strive to follow the open
community's best practices data will not
end up in a proprietary silo rather it
sits in a GCS bucket and can be accessed
and reused from any other environment
similarly compute uses native TCP
components which will work across the
stored in GCS what we hope to illustrate
with this reference implementation is to
demonstrate how we can stop building
more proprietary data silos in
biomedical research that will just
prevent the community from collaborating
efficiently if we follow the standards
and best practices we laid out solutions
like our reference implementation will
enable the construction of a
collaborative biomedical research
environment that can help researchers
accelerate discoveries and treatment now
I'll hand it back to Rahul to close out
our discussion thanks Jordan
and thanks Google for the opportunity
for this discussion today in summary
we're previewed how biomedical research
is transforming into a data science we
discussed the principles of how
biomedical data can be effectively
managed and analyzed in the Google cloud
platform and B showed you a reference
implementation in addition we discussed
how Google cloud platform allows us to
do biomedical research in a highly
scalable and cost-effective way in the
cloud and finally and most importantly a
cloud native solution for researchers to
collaborate and share their data with
one another is vitally important to
accelerate scientific discovery and find
new treatments for the many still
untreatable diseases
if you have any questions on this
presentation or the content please feel
free to reach out to us directly we have
included our contact information on this
slide thanks again for your time and
interest